so yesterday we did an army commercial
don't worry the marine corps has one for
you too
now some of you are in the marine corps
is this what it's like yeah
it's like night at the museum it is more
than a trial by fire
it is a rite of passage
a challenge to join the elite
and if you succeed if you can master
your fear
outsmart your enemy and never yield
and never ask a question why we're
fighting an 18-year war for a country
that is thousands of miles away from us
welcome to the marines
to yourself you will be changed forever
[Music]
the few the proud the marines
huh this just reminds me this reminds me
of the uh
that scene in generation kill when
they're driving he's like you should
have went into battle with your sword
brad
that would have been badass that was one
of the best scenes in generation killer
just talking about how they all got
conned into the marine corps
and he was like oh yeah i had a
recruiter at my high school and they're
like i bet this guy saw the commercial
with a guy in the dress blues kills a
dragon with a sword
[Laughter]
they're all just laughing about the
walmart wall of heroes
that's why dude that's why yesterday
like the military people love when we
make fun of them because oh yeah they're
just as cynical and broken
as as we are like there's you know most
of the guys that are
in the military at this point especially
the veterans that have been like
that have like 18 years in those guys
are the most cynical about their jobs
like they're not like
yo we're proud we're definitely like
they'll make they'll be the first ones
to make jokes about fighting for israel
they just won't say it too loud because
they don't want any officers
they don't want them to check their text
message like with the national guard and
then not be able to serve yeah but when
they're in a [ __ ] humvee that smells
like ball sweat and they're driving
around the desert you better believe
they're saying some really dark [ __ ]
this is so bad so he's fighting a lava
monster there's a lava monster it's it's
a runaway lava monster did we start a
war with the lava monsters
no mike you know why because we're
fighting them over there so we don't
have to fight them over here
what's the matter you don't want to show
like is it just the fact that
a lava monster helps keep the
recruitment numbers high and
i don't know probably calling in an air
strike on a [ __ ] on a on a [ __ ]
orphanage in the middle of iraq
probably wouldn't get the same numbers
i'm sorry but you know that mordor is
the only place of middle earth where you
could have butt sex
have you thought about that it's the
only place where all three monotheistic
religions that's [ __ ] correct
okay you could be an elf you could be an
orc
you could be a dwarf and you could live
there we should make could we make a
can we make a military commercial but
make it real
somebody help me out with this yeah can
we make a video where it's the same
music and it's like
the few the pro the let's get some
footage of like
like a [ __ ] missile hitting a
hospital
just hospitals getting blown to
smithereens schools getting blown up
the few the throne the marines farmers
getting shot in the [ __ ] throat
oh man
i love man i [ __ ] just love when they
would send the recruiters to high
schools
you know oh yeah i mean that was just so
predatory
and what's weird is like you know i
probably didn't want to join the
military back then
but for all the wrong reasons and now
i'm glad i didn't join the military for
all the right reasons
but regardless of your reason don't join
the military
i mean like i will say this unless we
need a mill we need in the military
so i'm pretty sure the military will
exist without the
2 000 people that watch the show uh mike
i don't think you know the sway we have
yeah i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure that the recruitment
will stay high i'm telling just you guys
that i like
don't join the military unless you're
puerto rican but no i mean honestly if
you are somebody who is
if you're somebody who is in a situation
that is seems to be almost like
irreversibly bad like
there are people whose lives are so
shitty that joining the military is
preferable
to staying in their hometown going to
community college and like
working at a [ __ ] car lot like that i
understand there are people out there
that
live in like legit live in dirt poor
areas that have no [ __ ] real
future unless they do something so i'm
saying like that's fine
but if you're just some guy that like
has a good throwing arm and has pretty
good grades and you're walking past that
recruitment station and they're like
hey you want to be a hero look them dead
in the eye and say
no no i don't you know why
because heroes get murdered eric in the
chat says
the few the proud the minorities
[Laughter]
this is a [ __ ] realistic military
commercial i'm four let's figure it out
let's do it
you want to serve your country and be
your hero kid no heroes die
all the time no thanks i'd rather be a
bum i'd rather be a [ __ ] coward who
lives like 75
past hillman would still be have a cushy
nfl nfl but postseason job on the espn
right now calling games that's all i'm
saying